>> WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
EVERYONE, MORE NOW
ON THE COLLAPSE OF RUSSIAN
GROUND FORCES IN NORTHEASTERN
UKRAINE.
KEEPS BLISTERING
COUNTEROFFENSIVE PUSHES ON.
BUT THESE TROOPS, NOT FAR FROM
THE BORDER WITH RUSSIA.
WELL, THEY SEEM TO HAVE A
MESSAGE THERE.
FOR MOSCOW.
THE RUSSIAN RETREAT IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST DEFEATS SINCE THE
WAR BEGAN IN FEBRUARY.
>> SO FAR THE TERRITORY HAS
BEEN RE-TAKEN FROM RUSSIAN
FORCES.
AMERICA'S MOST SENIOR DIPLOMAT
CALLS IT ENCOURAGING.
>> I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
WRONG TO PREDICT EXACTLY WHERE
THIS WILL GO AND WHEN IT WILL
GET THERE, HOW WILL GET.
THERE BUT, CLEARLY, WE HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS BY
THE UKRAINIANS.
>> EVEN TELL, NOW PRO RUSSIAN
SUPPORTERS ARE NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING UKRAINE STUNNING
GAMES ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
BUT FAR FROM ADMITTING THIS WAS
A FAILURE, SOMEONE PUTTING A
POSITIVE SPIN, SAYING THEY WERE
VASTLY OUTNUMBERS.
HERE IS CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE.
>> WE HAVE WARNED PEOPLE WITH
RUSSIA WITH THE KREMLIN
PROPAGANDA POSTING.
NO ONE'S READING IT ANYMORE.
AS UKRAINIAN FORCES TEAR IT
DOWN, THE WORDS OF A CELEBRATED
UKRAINIAN POET, ARE REVEALED
THINLY PAPERED.
>> THE FIGHT, AND YOU WILL WHEN
HE WRITES.
IT'S ONE POIGNANT MOMENT IN A
UKRAINIAN GAINS.
IN VILLAGES ACROSS VASTE --
THIS WAR RAVAGED COUNTRIES
KHARKIV REGION, UKRAINIAN
TROOPS ARE BEING GREETED AS --
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
FOR MONTHS, THESE PEOPLE HAVE
LIVED UNDER RUSSIAN GUNS.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
NOW IT'S UKRAINIAN GOWNS,
CELEBRATING THE RECAPTURE OF
STRATEGIC TANGS TOWNS LIKE
IZIUM, EASY TO, A CLEAN KEY
SUPPLY POINT FOR RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
, TROOPS WHO APPEARED TO HAVE
BEEN RIGHTED, WITH EQUIPMENT
DESTROYED OR JUST ABANDONED IN
THE FACE OF A LIGHTNING,
UKRAINIAN OFFENSIVE, HEAVY
ARMOR, AMMUNITION EVEN FOOD AND
CLOTHES LEFT BEHIND.
AS UKRAINIAN COMMANDERS SAY
THAT THEIR RUSSIAN ENEMY SIMPLY
TURNED AND RAN.
POWERFUL AMID --
FOR THE KREMLIN AND ITS
MILITARY RUSSIAN OFFICIALS ARE
PUTTING ON A VERY DIFFERENT
SPIN.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION AS THEY CALL, IT THE
DECISION WAS NAMED TO REGROUP
RUSSIAN TROOPS SAYS THIS
DEFENCE MINISTER SPOKESPERSON.
IT'S AN ORDERLY WITHDRAWAL OF
THE CHAOTIC RANKS ENSUES.
BUT EVEN ON PRO KREMLIN
TELEVISION THE WANTS TRIUMPHANT
MOOD, SEEMS TO SHIFT TOWARDS
REALITY, AND THE BLAME GAME IS
NOW IN FULL SWING THE PEOPLE
WHO CONVINCE PUTIN, A SPECIAL
OPERATION WOULD BE PASSED AND
EFFECTIVE, REALLY SET US UP,
COMPLAINS THIS PUNDIT.
SOMEONE MUST HAVE TOLD DON
UKRAINIANS WOULD SURRENDER HE
SAYS.
SIX MONTHS AGO, DID ANYONE
REALLY BELIEVE WE'D BE
SURRENDERING TOWNS, AND TRYING
TO REPEL A COUNTEROFFENSIVE IN
KHARKIV.
>> THIS IS A SERIOUS ARMY, THE
WEAPONS ARE SERIOUS TO AMID
HEATED EXCHANGES.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
UKRAINE'S DRAMATIC ADVANCE
SEEMS TO HAVE GENUINELY SHOCKED
RUSSIA.
[NOISE] >> AND THAT MAKES ITS
LEADER, WHO OVERSAW MOSCOW
ANNIVERSARY CELEBRATIONS IN THE
WEEKEND EVEN MORE UNPREDICTABLE
AND POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS.
ALREADY, RUSSIAN HARD-LINERS
ARE CALLING FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN
TO ACT, MOBILIZED TROOPS, AND
DOUBLE DOWN ON UKRAINE.
CALLS HE MAY NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO RESIST.
MATTHEW CHANCE, CNN, LONDON.
CALLS HE MAY NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO RESIST.
MATTHEW CHANCE, CNN,